the big thing i want to pick your brain
on so i'm so full disclosure
because this might entertain you people
would i would say things on the trail
like hey uh
quoting you i sometimes i attributed
sometimes i did and i knew you wouldn't
care
but i would say we have some of the
smartest engineers in the country
turning super computers into dopamine
delivery devices for
our kids and is having a disastrous
effect on uh our mental health
teenage girls in particular according to
jonathan hayden and eugene twenge's data
and then every parent in iowa new
hampshire
who heard this were like yeah because
they see their kids getting
addicted to their screens and you know
it's not great for their development
and then they would turn to me and say
what are we going to do about it and
then i would say
you know what we're going to do and
here's where
i don't know if you said this i said as
your president i'm going to start at a
pension detent
department of the attention economy and
i'm going to have my friend tristan
harris run it
just odd has been been trying to change
the design decisions of these tech
companies for years
now most of them you know just gave like
uh oh like you know andrew
knows someone specifically who who has
the right thinking on this
but if we were to play that scenario out
what do we need to do to try and
uh humanize our technology and our use
of it
first i just want to say a few things to
what you shared um
man yeah well i just want to say i i
appreciate it so much that you
like with universal basic income and
like with other aspects of your platform
you
i think have always prioritized a kind
of public education
in your work and trying to help people
understand and elevate issues that are
not being talked about and using your
presidential campaign to do that i think
that
was amazing you did that with ubi and
you've also been doing that with the
attention economy
and um you know i think you helped make
it even a bigger issue and i
just really want to say i really
appreciated that that you you led the
way
uh on elevating it as as i think to its
rightful position as one of the top
issues facing society because it's
underneath and exacerbating
all the other issues it makes it
impossible to solve any problems if we
can't even agree on reality
exactly exactly and that's what we say
in the film so clearly is if we can't
agree on reality we can't solve any
problem whether it's climate change
poverty or
social justice and racism or whatever we
wanna we wanna deal with
so truth be told this is not an easy
thing to regulate
um it has to do with core business
models i do think we can look
to ways that the climate movement thinks
about
an increasing overtime tax
um to carbon you know to carbon
externality setting a price on carbon
you know so essentially
as we've talked about um this is an
extractive economy where instead of
extracting oil out of the ground and
then
producing you know climate change at a
global level
in the commons depleting the
environmental commons and also
eroding the the life support systems of
the planet that's the
fossil fuel economy in this case we have
an extractive economy
built on not just extracting human
attention but as we talked about in an
earlier interview we did
fracking for human attention because
we're worth more also when we're
multitasking
it's really quickly on that we're worth
more when you have a tablet a phone and
your television up and that triples the
size of the attention economy because
now you're paying attention to three
things
so antarctic
but one one thing that very much like
that when you use the metaphor of
fracking for attention you start to see
that we're selling just like the
financial crisis thinner and thinner
slices
of human attention as if it's worth the
same as
valuable concentrated attention but it's
kind of junk attention just like
we're selling thinner and thinner credit
default swap type you know
junk instruments financial instruments
and selling it as if it's this bigger
thing
and propping up this kind of inflated
advertising attention market
so i think one thing we can do is we can
correct for that inflation
um and i think there's one study from a
couple years ago where facebook was
found to inflate
the amount of advertising reporting that
it did for
um their advertisers by 900 meaning they
exaggerated
how much um the viewership or clicks
there was by 900 percent
so that's just like you know a financial
broker exaggerating the value of
you know a financial instrument by by a
lot so we can kind of
clean up um comprehensively this
systemically fragile
fragility creating system so much like
you want to
you can't just say we're going to get
completely off of oil in one year and
carbon
prices are going to be set to a million
dollars a ton and
we're going to move over you set up a
transition plan over 10 years
so i think what we need is a transition
plan from
each company maximizing how much
attention that they
kind of extract to winding down
how much commodification of human
attention that we can do over time
one model of this actually comes from
the way that we regulate energy
companies because it used to be that pg
e or con edison or whatever your energy
company is they're a
for-profit company theoretically they
want you to use as much energy as
possible so
leave the lights on leave the faucets on
maximize your just wasting of
energy and you're maximizing climate
pollution you know
activity and behavior they can even put
those nests in your home and then
maximize how much you use to like
manipulate you into using the most
that would be a kind of dystopian
reality our our recommended home
temperature
is 95 degrees
and get you to change it all the time
and you know um anyway
so obviously that would be an extractive
kind of business
and it's fundamentally misaligned with
the commons because it accelerates
climate change et cetera
so we've dealt with this problem before
we actually have regulated utilities
that um set um seasonal targets for how
much money you can make as a utility
off of a certain amount of energy so for
example if there's a seasonal
availability of so much energy
it costs this much for this lower tier
usage and then if you're a consumer and
you use let's say beyond that amount
because it's a hot summer they actually
double charge you for that next phase of
of energy that you're using except those
extra profits don't go into the
coffers of pg e or con edison they go
into a public fund
uh that actually invests in the
renewable energy infrastructure that we
need
so that's a nice i don't know if you've
got that it's sort of a nice transition
plan
of oh like oh i caught that
i don't know how i explained these
things you probably know these things
better than i do frankly but no no no no
no so let me let me just try and walk
through this just for fun
so let's say um you and i are getting
together and we're part of the
department of detention economy and
we're like all right
hey facebook here's the deal um
we find you excessively extractive
in terms of the amount of attention
you're getting from folks so
step number one stop exaggerating the
amount of time we actually spend on you
that's that's number one but number two
um for every bit of attention you get
beyond a certain period let's call it
like our uh four plus four
uh teenager like there's actually like
some negative social value associated
with that
um so we're going to have you
pay a penalty um and then use that
penalty then to fund
some alternatives let's call it like
little leagues
or whatever like we would put something
that
that would be like the anti um
facebook type of counter measure
uh is that more or less accurate
well i also want to say this is a tiny
part of a probably a more comprehensive
way of dealing with these problems but i
think
um there's an there's a part of it which
is that we have to remove some of the
perverse
um incentives um yeah what you're saying
now
reminds me of something i said when i
went to the can
con whatever you say call it uh
pronounce it advertising festival
where um you know we were talking to the
advertisers that fund all this activity
and these mental health harms
and said um you know after there's a
mental health crisis from kids
and there's a loneliness crisis
someone's gonna ask the question who
paid for all of this to happen
and it's obviously these advertisers and
one of the things we proposed was
imagine you just simply cannot make
money from usage
between let's say midnight and six in
the morning if you're a tech company
that disincentivizes usage of um sort of
late night lonely use that sort of the
low willpower period
of of use now that's that's definitely i
don't know what you're talking about
tristan i have never
done any low willpower ted tech social
media use between those hours
[Laughter]
i think you you were the superhuman will
power uh one among us
kidding we've all done it but it's but i
love that idea so much where you
cordoned off
a number of hours where you're like look
extracting attention in these hours is
not not a good thing
it's like treating a park you know those
trees some of the trees we extract and
we turn into lumber other trees we say
this is part of a national park and
they're for walking and exploring and
enjoying
right and it's like some of our
attention can be maybe
you know part of a a system that
obviously wants to commoditize it but
that's another thing is there's sort of
a violation of
turning a live humanness and a live
human choice
into these dead slabs of human behavior
through behavior modification engines
right so we turn like a live
consciousness
into this sort of dead end consciousness
in which your behavior is more or less
predictable because we've
taken what could be a free choice and
turn it into an unconscious habit
which is a form of kind of like dead
lumber as to a tree what dead
you know human behavior is to a live
human being there's many different
aspects of this that i think we have to
correct i think what we need here is
overall something more
comprehensive just like with the
financial crisis if you asked me andrew
and said what's the
one law that we passed that's going to
fix all this i like your approach that
this is sort of an ongoing issue and
that we need a cabinet level
department of the attention economy to
uh to deal with these problems
well let's dig into the tool kit a
little bit more because i'm already
learning a ton from you
um so i i love seeing it as
something of a negative externality like
attention beyond a certain point where
you say look
like i was thinking beyond our x
is probably not a great thing for you i
love your saying look
between midnight and six am probably
terrible for
for teenagers to be uh facebooking it up
or or whatnot
like uh what just throw a few things out
there
like that also belong somewhere in like
the consideration center toolkit
yeah you know we're going to be
publishing um some more on this on our
website
soon i have some of it up here right now
but i think a more comprehensive
approach
is something like what we had for the
financial crisis where we had a
comprehensively risk
creating system and we needed
comprehensive basel iii reforms in
europe or the dodd-frank kind of reforms
the united states
i know there's some problems with that
but that's thematically what we would
want to be going after
so we need protection for kids privacy
for people transparency for platforms
you can imagine
you get section 230 protections for
content but not for
amplification or recommendation systems
and in exchange for getting section 230
protections for those who don't know
it's what prevents is what enables
platforms to not be liable for bad
content on their platforms
but in exchange for that there has to be
transparency
to the public and to many civil society
groups to be able to say
which things we want to measure about
the use or
or prevalence of certain kinds of
content
so that we can actually do a better job
of regulating them because we don't even
have transparency now about
how bad is the teenage mental health
problem how many users beneath the age
of 16
are using it between two and four in the
morning if we had transparency we could
actually
make them report not to a board of
directors but to a board of the people
based on these metrics that matter to us
in a democratically governed society
oh that is enormous so modifying section
230 in those ways would be
huge because in many ways uh that is
these companies licensed to uh
operate and print money really that's
right you know that
and this was written in 96 before any of
these companies even existed like we
couldn't
i'm sure they anticipated youtube and
facebook and tiktok you know many years
later
uh yeah so we need to examine
this license essentially and what you're
suggesting is a difference between
um posting content um and then
uh spreading advertising content or uh
messages or videos that there's some
kind of commercial incentive attached to
um so that's a very that's a very
interesting distinction
um the other interesting thing you're
attaching to it is to say look
we're gonna give you this and in some
cases this franchise is worth you know
billions even trillions of dollars but
in return we get data
they get real data about what the actual
public harms are
because if you compare this to a
negative externality where you look at
you know for example with pollution you
look around and say okay there's a
you know there are negative effects
through climate change and this one we
actually need the data the social media
companies have in order to
measure um a lot of the harms that's
right and so this is table stakes this
is not the thing that answers the
problems this is the sort of
prerequisite for being able to do
anything a metaphor i often have
anderson so using these
climate change analogies is it's like
facebook is like exxon but they're the
exon of human anxiety
except they also don't just own the kind
of you know extraction of
oil they also own the entire satellite
network that we have to observe and
measure how much co2
so they actually control the measurement
of how bad the problem is
so this is ridiculous it's almost like
it's you know if you take the monopoly
conversation it's a vertically
integrated company that owns both the
measurement
you know either the exclusive access to
measurement of the harm
and also the harm creation that's a
vertically integrated perverse
sort of company there's also other
aspects freedom from manipulation
accountability for harms enabling more
competition and we can to dig into that
because it's less about as you said
magically breaking them up causes the
removal of misinformation or addiction
in society because you still have a race
to the bottom to create
those problems um and then also national
security because we haven't talked about
that
that you know while we've been obsessed
you know by some
uh folks and politicians of protecting
our physical borders
we've been leaving our digital borders
wide open and this is really important
because if russia or china try to fly a
plane into the physical united states
where they try to get across the
passport controls we have
huge billions of dollars invested in
either shooting down that plane or
stopping them at the border but it's
none of us would accept it
none of us would accept the fact that
you have you have 70 countries right now
that are
uh investing in misinformation and
everyone's like oh you know if you had
70 countries flying planes through our
airspace we'd all be like what the heck
is going on that's exactly right and so
and
so if you think about it as how much of
the surface area of our
of our country's activity is happens in
the physical world
and how much of that surface area is
moving into the virtual world of kind of
facebook instagram clicks advertising
email etc
and more and more of our economic
activity is moving from the physical to
the digital but we don't protect the
digital borders
so if russia and china try to fly an
information plane
into the virtual united states instead
of being met by the pentagon to shoot it
down they're met by a facebook algorithm
with a white glove that says yeah
exactly which zip code
or minority group would you like to
target with more divisive information
that could stir up culture wars
so this is a urgent national security
threat that we've been meaning to try to
get
you know more into the agenda because i
think we don't we massively
underestimate the vulnerability of
culture
you know after world war ii you know big
powers like russia china iran
turkey they're not going to you know
attack the united states with nuclear
weapons anymore they can't do kinetic
warfare
and so what would you do you would
actually want to take the divisions in a
country that already exist
walk over their virtual borders and stir
up culture wars and racial divides
everywhere
which is exactly what we're seeing them
doing um we also know that russia has
gone after
ex-u.s veteran groups and trying to sow
more discontent about
you know uh uh they're not so dark we
know that they're right we know that
russia is going after environmentalist
groups
in fact they actually go after
pro-environmentalists anti-fracking
us advocates like greenpeace and mag and
amplify them because what happens if in
the u.s we don't frac
we have to buy more foreign oil from
where from russia
so there's many different aspects to
this problem but i think what people
need to know
is that this is in all of our interests
it's not a partisan issue
it's really a a global issue and a
national security issue
that affects everyone thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you